chef sessions headed to Capitol Hill
today where Democrats who couldn't
coherently grill him over alleged Russia
collusion grasp for straws humiliating
themselves and entertaining us we will
review the highlights then Joshy asthma
and campus reforms Cabot Phillips joined
the panel of deplorable z-- to discuss
Trump slam dunk on getting China to
release UCLA basketball players huh now
they can't all be winners
the total Democrat media silence on the
congressional candidate accused of
stalking and sending lewd photos to a
New Mexico woman and conservatives
victory over Media Matters
in the great Sean Hannity Keurig coffee
cough fa war of 2017 I am Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a great way to wake up today I got
to watch the sessions testimony and
Democrats just absolutely humiliate
themselves especially Sheila jackson-lee
my favorite member of Congress maybe my
favorite member of the federal
government before we get to all of the
highlights though I have to tell you a
sad story I have to tell you this is a
personal story it comes from my own life
you've probably experienced this having
watched the show and listened to the
show there was one time that I needed to
hire a producer and I considered my
options I walked around the sidewalks I
looked for people muttering to
themselves and sleeping in gutters with
a bottle of booze in one hand or
what-have-you and I thought that would
be the best way to find a candidate
that's how we ended up with Marshall as
the producer but what I should have done
is going to zip recruiter if only I had
known it's too late now
but if only I had known we could have
gotten one of the most qualified people
in the country because that's where they
all are with zip recruiter super girder
you can post your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards with just one
click
nobody has time we actually have that
you know walking around the street
looking for muttering people aside we
actually do hire people a fair bit and
it's very complicated if you use other
tools so you got a post to this and you
got a post to that and you got to follow
this and you don't get a notification
for this one and that one of this one
zip recruiter makes it all so easy you
could rest easy knowing that your job is
being seen by the right candidates is
because zip recruiter puts it smart
matching technology to work it actively
notifies qualified candidates about your
job within minutes of posting so that
you receive the best possible matches
that's why zip recruiter is different
from all of those other ones that don't
do anything you just pay them some money
and you click a button and nothing
happens
unlike other hiring sites zip recruiter
doesn't depend on the right candidates
finding you it's not just a board it's
not just you pin it up there it actually
finds them and notifies them and that
way you'll get the best candidates you
can even get a story on the interview
process by adding screening questions to
your job post and then you can help
identify the most qualified candidates
and you also don't need to waste time
going through stacks and stacks of
resumes I'm out here in Hollywood the
way that people deal with resumes and
hedge
and out here is they get it in the mail
they immediately throw it in the trash
so you don't need to worry about going
through all those piles that is why 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
get a qualified candidate through the
site in just one day that's an amazing
statistic because we do these searches
for people seriously and it'll go on for
weeks weeks and month two months and
this 80 percent of employers who are on
zip recruiter they get a quality
candidate in just one day then the easy
to use app recruiter dashboard lets you
manage your hiring process from start to
finish all in one place zip recruiter is
the smartest way to hire and today you
can find out why zip recruiter has been
used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results because right now my listeners
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right if some of you if
unbelievably it's some Michael Knowles
show listeners are in a position to hire
people I believe that we're all good
capitalists we're all serious people we
know all the news we we have all the co
FFA then you can go check it out right
now for immediate results it's free it's
just zip recruiter dot-com /m KS you
know what that stands for
of course you do the Michael Knowles
show zip recruiter comm slash MKS one
more time to try it for free where do
you go Marshall Jeana where you go yeah
where is that zip recruiter com he
doesn't know this why did not use super
critter why didn't I use it
zip recruiter god / MKS okay let's get
to the news attorney General Sessions
headed up to Capitol Hill today in the
build-up Democrats boasted of how they
were gonna grill Jeff Sessions on Russia
trouble is they don't have a whole lot
to work with because as left-wing
commentator vans Jones pointed out
[Applause]
yeah that's a nothing burger whoops so
instead we were treated to a typical
tour de force from Democrat Sheila
jackson-lee
here she is I took the liberty of
reviewing federal crimes against
children particularly those dealing with
sexual or physical abuse as you well
know Lea kaufman wendy miller debbie
watson gibson gloria thakur dicen and
beverly young Nelson these young women
have accused this individual judge Moore
who is running for a federal office the
United States Senate of child sexual
activity do you believe these young
women I am have no reason to doubt these
young women and with that in mind if you
believe these young women do you believe
Judge Moore should be seated in the
Senate if he wins and would you
introduce investigations by the DOJ
regarding his actions we will evaluate
every case as to whether or not it
should be investigated this kind of case
would normally be a state case I would
say representative Jackson Lee that the
ethics people at the Department of
Justice and I've talked to them about
that when this campaign started it's the
seat I used to hold they advised me that
the Attorney General should not be
involved in this campaign I have thanked
friends in the camp I should continue if
he comes to the United States Senate
garna Walter Scott Tamir rice my
question is as I hold up the poster
dealing with the report under your
jurisdiction black identity extremists
it is interesting to me that you are
opposing individuals who are opposing
lethal force similar to the attack on
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King on
COINTELPRO but there seems to be no
report dealing with the tiki torch
parade in Charlottesville chanting
chooses will not replace us why is there
an attack on black
activist versus any reports dealing with
all right and the white nationalist what
is your favorite breakfast cereal as if
Froot Loops what it won the 1968 World
Series how you what why are these the
reason she's asking these ridiculous
questions is of course that she doesn't
really have anything to say about Russia
because this entire testimony today was
a ridiculous parade and a charade but
she let's just put this into context she
is asking the Attorney General in his
official capacity to comment on a Senate
race on a on a Republican candidate for
Senate in Alabama she's then asking him
to comment on a I suppose a potentially
criminal case from 40 years ago that
would typically be handled by the state
anyway then so obviously sessions who
has been around a long time he's a
pretty smart guy he says well with due
respect this has nothing to do with my
role and I'm here I'm supposed to be
testifying in my role as Attorney
General not as a Fox News contributor or
whatever they're trying to make him into
then she brings up black lives matter
and and looking at some of the protests
and riots that have come out of black
lives matter and she says why aren't you
looking into white supremacists or yada
yada yada now he says I don't know what
you're talking about lady or it's just
business as usual the DOJ it is worth
pointing out though that in August the
Geo DOJ sent a major release that they
had gotten the largest conviction of
white supremacists Arian nation prison
inmates in US history that happened just
a few months ago is the biggest skinhead
you know white supremacist gang prison
conviction in history eighty nine
inmates was what they got and in 2016 in
the United States just some interesting
statistics there were fifty seven
hundred seventy hate crimes in the
United States according to DOJ
statistics forty six point three percent
of those were committed by white people
but that doesn't really make a whole lot
of sense and I didn't believe this
statistic so I looked a little further
down there they're defining Hispanic
people as white people for that
statistic so when you look for for
non-hispanic whites
that number drops to 26.1% in that
category nevertheless during testimony
that where we're supposed to be talking
about Russia we're supposed to be
talking about anything that the Attorney
General really can comment on this is
the kind of nonsense because Sheila
jackson-lee
either doesn't understand what her role
is or what the role of this testimony is
or realizes she's got nothing and just
needs to try to grab as many crazy
headlines as she can you know I never
miss an opportunity to watch clips of
Sheila jackson-lee
I'll be on YouTube sometimes and I'll be
you know on YouTube you go from one
video to the next I will go on an hour's
long clip parade of Sheila jackson-lee
she is the most entertaining person in
DC so here just a couple other greatest
hits from her my chairman and others for
giving us an opportunity to have a
deliberative constitutional discussion
that reinforces the sanctity of this
nation and how well it is that we have
lasted some 400 years operating under
Constitution between type 1 and type but
you did say it again I'm trying to put
my comments into context ma'am
I'm aware of the difference between type
1 and type 2 diabetes' on the ogee but
you're not a doctor I'm not a doctor are
you you're not a doctor and I love we've
been under the Constitution for 400
years
it's served us very well for these 400
years it hasn't been 400 years yes this
one 400 years since the landing of
Plymouth but Sharia or under 400 years
we've been laboring under this so god I
love her she is just absolutely fabulous
then the Republicans came around and it
became much more coherent after just
Democrat inanity but still there were
some problems with the Republican
testimony here we have the cannons being
turned on Hillary Clinton as the chief
law enforcement official in this country
do you share similar concerns and in
your opinion is it legal under current
law for a presidential campaign to hide
its funding of the compilation and
dissemination of political dirt on its
opponent by using a law firm to directly
pay for the work I would think that
those matters are worthy of concern
raishin bought as to the details of them
and for me to express an ultimate
comment today I'm unable to do so okay
now obviously Republicans want some
investigations of Hillary we've had
people clamoring for this since the
election into the Clinton Foundation
into the uranium one deal in to
Hillary's collusion with Russia but
listen to what Jeff Sessions doesn't say
he says he can't comment on that matter
why can't he comment on that matter is
it the case that there's an
investigation going on is it the case
that special counsels looking into it we
know that Tony Podesta in the Podesta
group were under investigation by Muller
why can t there's always a little smirk
when you see Jeff Sessions testifying
and I just wonder what that smirk means
perhaps Republicans are getting what
they want but so far the DOJ has been
slow to go after Hillary Congressman Jim
Jordan conservative member of the House
Republican caucus has gotten fed up with
this and he's called for a special
counsel so on Twitter this morning was
calls for a special counsel we're
popping up I think this is because
people don't understand what a special
counsel is the reason for a special
counsel is when the DOJ when an
investigation would create a conflict of
interest if it were undertaken by the
DOJ so the DOJ can't do it because of
some conflict of interest and therefore
they appoint a special counsel to come
in and do it for them so that there is
no impropriety and no political dealing
that's going on during the investigation
now
sessions has apparently sent a memo to
the DOJ asking for their evaluation on
whether or not they should investigate
whether or not a special counsel should
be imported for Hillary Clinton it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense for it
to from the information that we have
right now seems like the DOJ could just
investigate this themselves that said
you know there are enough special
counsels don't do it the DOJ should
investigate her it was a mistake that we
have the special counsel from Bob Mulder
but it is what it is and we are where we
are it is not unusual for multiple
special counsels to be going on at once
you might remember the great days of the
Bill Clinton administration when there
were I think 150 million special
counsels that were floating around the
White House were actually seven there
were eight under Ronald Reagan it that
that is an
uncommon but if we want to go after
Hillary Clinton seems to me more special
councils would not be the way to go we
should do it where we have some control
and not let this thing get completely
out of bounds as it seems the mauler
investigation is so much grandstanding
few answers came out of today's charade
for analysis
we bring on joshi asthma and campus
reforms Cabot Phillips but before we
talked to those guys we have to talk
about something much more interesting
than anything either of them have had to
say and that would be ring or second
sponsor today ring we've talked about
them before they are an excellent
company rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer a byproduct of this
mission is they keep the lights on here
which is another reason that we love
them but today over 1 million people use
the amazing ring video doorbell to
protect their homes ring knows that home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end at the front door so now
they have a new product this is when
it's really cool it is the ring
floodlight cam so you know the
floodlight cam obviously the criminals
in my audience know that when you're
trying to break into someone's house you
go in there a floodlight cam or that
floodlight rather hits you and then you
run away scared well what this does is
puts a camera in that floodlight so just
like rings amazing doorbell the
floodlight cam is a motion-activated
camera that connects right to your phone
with HD video and two-way audio that
lets you know the moment that someone
steps onto your property it uploads it
to the cloud so even if that robber
climbs up the ladder and rips it out and
runs away with it you'll have it in the
cloud you'll be able to see it right on
your phone so you can see and speak to
visitors even set off an alarm right
from your phone so if you're you know
for me I like to sleep about 14 hours a
day and I take usually seven to eight
months of vacation a year so if I'm away
is snoozing on a beach somewhere and I
see that some bad guys trying to break
into my home I can set off an alarm
right from my phone
whether you are home or away the ring
floodlight cam lets you keep an eye on
your home from anywhere you'll
immediately know what is going on and it
is the ultimate in home security you
know in the old days we had neighborhood
watch we had those really clunky home
security systems that you had to install
and they were extremely expensive and
paid all these fees that's over it's a
21st century get with the 21st century
ring is an amazing deal you'll save a
lot of money you'll keep your home
really
right now right now you can save up to
150 dollars off of a ring home security
kit because they know that the viewers
of the Michael Noel's show they probably
live in pretty bad areas they probably
make the best decisions in their lives
you know so they're giving you $150 off
up to $150 off of this security kit when
you go to ring.com slash Knowles
that's Keo wles like Beyonce ring.com
slash Knowles and what what is really
amazing they did a study in LA in a kind
of bad neighborhood of La they gave out
a bunch of ring products and they
noticed within six months a 55%
reduction in home burglaries you can't
you can't argue with those statistics it
is really really good so go there right
now ring calm / Knowles
all right panel how you doing panel
listen I want to talk to you but I can't
we're running late today we have the
conversation coming up so right after
this I'm going to be doing the the next
episode the third episode of The Daily
wires conversation it is at 5:00 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific there is still
time so only subscribers can ask the
questions anybody can watch it on the
website Facebook YouTube become a
subscriber to ask me any question in the
world how do you become a subscriber you
go to daily wire calm DLE wire comma
what do you get for it I know we're all
capitalists were all good conservatives
you get me you got the under Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show blah blah
blah blah blah you get this you want to
talk about home security once like
Hillary Clinton tries to creep over and
sneak into your house and take all your
freedom away then that that ring home
security kid is gonna blast you and what
you can do is catch all of her delicious
leftist tears in the leftist tears
tumblr it doesn't matter if she's a
little hot if she's a little cold we all
know she's cold blooded you'll get them
there they're always salty and delicious
go over to Daley wire calm right now
we'll be right back to talk about all of
the important news with the great panel
[Music]
cabott Josh thank you for being here we
have an expert panel I can't help but
notice that Josh you've positioned
yourself in front of every single book
in the world
I'm gonna guess you at about 1% of those
you've skimmed about 1% there's no less
than one presumes look at cavities
they're just a white wall my look at my
bookshelf compared to yours for
Democrats there I have a few books here
propping up my computer but how else am
I supposed to evoke intelligence in the
21st century in 2017 it is all about
appearances and virtue signaling so
let's get to the news folks look at the
cavity's testimony early Tuesday morning
3 UCLA basketball players were released
from Chinese custody for shoplifting and
they safely boarded a nine a.m. Delta
flight to come home why is that
according to all available reports it's
because President Trump told Chinese
President Xi Jinping to make it happen
Josh the consensus view is that Trump is
a blundering idiot on the brink of
sending us into nuclear war but the
consensus view is also almost always
wrong
is Trump a foreign policy maven a matter
Nick for the 21st century what do you
think so first in regard to the story
The Wall Street Journal reported this
story and NBC CNN all done picked it up
it's clear that he intervened he spoke
to president G personally and he got the
job done which is a huge feat you know
it's when for national go for Nationals
go abroad I mean when American citizens
go abroad and you go into these hostile
foreign countries anything could happen
we saw with otto warmbier North Korea
that was incredibly dangerous but but
Trump Trump got the job done and he he
he displayed his negotiating skills well
that that's actually what I want to
bring up because people make fun of the
art of the deal all the time they say
well was ghostwritten he's probably
never even read
you know he's busy running this company
and running that company but Cabot is is
this the art of the deal and if so what
is the secret to the art of the deal I
saw some people on Twitter comparing
this to when you know the Iranian
hostage crisis ended on Ronald Reagan's
you know first day in office some people
there I love it's that extreme to where
you know there were all these all these
victories it is obviously a victory I
think maybe the difference is that
President Trump you know has taken a
much harder line throughout his campaign
he pretty much had this whole narrative
of being tough on China and being tough
on every other country so I guess maybe
that's having an impact and also I think
the Trump that we saw throughout the
election and really we see on the
day-to-day basis and on Twitter is not
the Trump that many of these world
leaders get I think a lot of them are
pleasantly surprised when they see his
willingness to you know compromise with
them and he is a businessman an
international businessman at that so I
think that's helping his clout with some
of these foreign leaders but there's
always a middle ground I don't think
it's that he's this you know world class
you know number one best deal maker in
the world it's also not these a bubbling
idiot the way the media is making it out
to be there's a middle ground there but
there's not too many other way to swing
this as other than a victory for the
Trump administration especially on the
PR front and getting these guys home and
yeah president a Bay of Japan clearly
seems to like him or Prime Minister
rather clearly seems to have been
impressed by him he's always giving him
gifts and silly hats and he does seem to
have made an impact on world leaders now
Josh you're a foreign policy guy how do
you rate this Asia trip is it his poll
numbers are increasing so it seems to be
affecting the public has he handled
himself a better than people thought he
would and be better than his predecessor
for instance well his predecessor didn't
do much as far as you know Chinese he
led for most ladies what are you talking
about well he had this idea of a
president Obama had to say do you have
an Asia pivot so he wanted to leave the
Middle East behind let it crash and burn
and move on to Asia you know establish
trade relationships strengthen the bond
there he never got there because the
quagmire in the Middle East kept pulling
him back President Trump seems to really
be
well at this balancing act you know he's
taking care of Isis he's getting the job
done there and he's he's he's talking to
Asian leaders he's is trying to you know
he's trying to strengthen bonds there I
will say that some of his rhetoric on
trade I'm somewhat opposed to but what
about this what about his action on
trade because we were all nervous we
were told we're going to get tariffs and
trade wars and none of that has happened
was it bluster was it just a negotiating
position or are you still afraid that
we're gonna dive into something a lot of
it was this populist kind of rhetoric
and when he gets to the negotiating room
I think he's a lot more realistic about
what's required about the importance of
us Chinese bilateral trade relationships
and from everything we're hearing it
went smoothly president G was satisfied
our partners in the South Pacific were
satisfied even even the media they
didn't have much to criticize him on so
it went well we don't know yet how much
came out of those meetings so we have to
wait and see what the White House says
what the Treasury Department says what
State Department says absolutely and I
do want to bring it back a little bit to
Russia as the final point on this on
this foreign policy and this Asia trip
all we've heard a better the relentless
drumbeats of Russia Russia Russia Russia
your Europe the foreign policy guy in
the panel today is Van Jones right is
Russia ultimately a nothing burger I
think it is when it comes to the Trump
there was no collusion at least there's
no evidence of collusion but you know I
said from the beginning that General
Michael Flynn was dirty he got 15
million dollars from the government of
Turkey a couple guys in the periphery
Paul Manafort George papadopolis those
guys they're questionable but they were
marginal characters in the Trump
campaign so two two two solid
our campaign and to say that Trump is
dirty or he's corrupt is is as Van Jones
says nothing burger it's it's it's made
up but there are some questions
lingering questions about these
periphery figures mana Ford Papadopoulos
Flynn we should question them and we
should question what they're about Cabot
this brings up a question for you I have
a dichotomy for you George papadopolis
or George Stephanopoulos the media have
worked on this Russia thing forever and
ever with this absolutely useless
testimony today that was funny I enjoyed
that part it was a nice way to wake up
but the American people seem to not like
that you know they don't want Russians
interfering in our elections they don't
want us collaborating with foreign
powers or yada yada yada but they really
hate the media they really hate the
media the most so which poses the
greater threat WikiLeaks
sending a couple tweets to Donald Trump
jr. or a corrupt news media run by
people like George sucka Lippa guesses
Andrew Clavin calls him that are
shilling for Democrats all the time I
mean if it's again I don't want to make
big sweeping statements about the rushed
investigation and until it is concluded
I think the American people would really
do well to get the facts in this and not
have to deal with the media rhetoric in
the big picture though if you know if
the investigation continues to not show
any you know evidence of collusion as it
hasn't so far I do think the problem of
the media is a larger long-term problem
for the country when people don't know
who to trust they don't even know what's
going on it's just a sensationalist
drivel that's coming out from the
mainstream media where everything has to
be the end of the world and with so many
different things you know spelling doom
anything President Trump does it's you
know we're you know going towards the
edge of oblivion and it's hard for
American people to keep up with what
it's supposed to be killing them that
day wake up every day like what's the
narrative like what's supposed to be
scary I mean the president will be doing
today you know how near is our country
to you know following off and the
American people's bid it's sad that
they've many of them have fallen for
this but again I think the media is to
blame and it's the sensationalism where
if everything is sensational then
thing is and the media doesn't realize
that and they're either sensationalist
or they're dead silent on it because
there was this Pete did you hear I'm
sure you haven't did you hear about the
congressional candidate Democrat
congressional candidate David alcone who
has been arrested in New Mexico for
stalking a woman and sending her photos
of his genitals you haven't heard about
that because not a single mainstream
news source is covering it because
alcone is a Democrat not one when you
look it up it's like the Santa Fe
shopping cart Tribune or the local
Albuquerque shopping cart dispatcher you
know these really local papers
no one is covering up meanwhile
mainstream media are doing their best to
black out Trump's overseas trip with
tabloid coverage of roy moore's alleged
sexual misdeeds forty years ago Josh in
the face of this flagrant media bias is
it any wonder that people will still
vote for Roy Moore well let's be clear
the Democratic Congressional Committee
has already come out come out and
condemned Marie happened a week ago to
we two weeks ago right they came out
after the fact and there's clear
hypocrisy though don't don't get me
wrong I think you're right I think that
there's going to be push back against
these allegations on more people may
vote for them anyway which i think is
unfortunate but there is this double
standard but is it what do we mean by
unfortunate I mean I get it a a lot of
this testimony is very compelling
especially that the Gloria Allred
interview that came out yesterday the
the only thing that makes me not believe
that interview is the Gloria Allred was
there as the main issue with it but
there are issues on the line here we're
talking about freedom we're talking
about a razor-thin senate majority we're
talking about issues that will affect
your freedom and mine your national
security and mine your constitutional
adherence and mine cabin is there a good
argument for voting for roy more even if
the charges are true even if forty years
ago who is a weird creep and even if the
worst charges are true and he was
kind of vicious guy is there still an
argument to vote for him because we're
talking about politics and we're talking
about freedom and we're talking about
how our government will compose itself
both on the international front and here
in the United States i'ma catch some
flack for this and I've been getting
some you know hate for some other
conservatives on social media for this
but I truly would rather we lose an
election then have to explain to our
children the future why we supported a
guy who was accused of being a rapist
who was accused of having relationships
with fourteen-year-old girls as a grown
man I think that certain things you
don't compromise on and I don't think we
want to be the party that is electing a
guy who's accused of all this now again
there needs to be a due process we need
to make sure that we're getting the
facts on this but there can be no
process there can't be there was 40
years later there's Astrid limitations
on many of these issues but again as it
stands now I tend to believe many of
these accusers I I think that looking at
the evidence since mounting up against
him it doesn't look good at the very
least he's a complete creeper and you
know what grown man is going around
hanging out with high school girls
trying to pick up young girls at the
mall I think that is not someone new
it's that you know it's something we
want to be promoting in the party but as
far as the actual election itself goes I
don't think that mix McConnell coming
out and saying don't vote for him it's
gonna drive anyone in Alabama away from
voting
well it's but looking at the vitriol
that many people in Alabama have towards
the Republican establishment the more
old-school senators in DC to come out
and say we don't want this guy in the
Senate I think the more and may help him
get votes in Alabama again I don't agree
with that strategy but I do think that
you know looking at logically in Alabama
I think that could be you know helping
him in some but on the morality of this
issue and I'm not sure which way it
really falls let's not forget if if
Republicans still go out there I mean
none of us are in Alabama but if
Republicans in Alabama go out and they
vote for Roy Moore and then he's seated
as a US senator and we maintain our
Senate majority and we a good Pro
Liberty legislation passed pray you know
constitutionally a constitutional
legislation passed and legislation to
the Constitution if we maintain that
majority and then we have a stave
against impeachment or a State against
conviction of the president what would
you rather do in 40 years say yeah there
was a really creepy guy probably not a
very good guy who was in the Senate for
a while and that's probably not good or
would you rather say yeah because we
decided that accusations from 40 years
ago are enough to knock off a can Senate
candidate we lost our majority and we
had to enshrine Obamacare and we didn't
get tax reform we lost our presidency
because he was impeached and we didn't
get any decent judges and your first
amendments gone and your second
amendments gone but hey I feel good
about myself because we didn't support
that really creepy guy 'men team like a
clear moral question to me Josh what do
you think no I conservatives are going
to condemn Harvey Weinstein
conservatives are gonna come condemn
these Hollywood liberal elites there has
to be consistency and why Harvey
Weinstein doesn't adjudicate whether or
not my government encroaches on my
freedom or not Harvey Weinstein is a
gross producer in Hollywood who makes
bad movies and some good movies but he's
a bad guy and and we're talking about
the Senate well the distinction I'm
trying to make here is between this
guy's weird personal life 40 years ago
and the and the politics of it and the
the liberty of it and the free there's a
difference though I I think there's a
difference between a weird personal life
and in a legal personal life and if
we're gonna be the party of morality and
the party of law and order how can we
stand by a guy who anything these these
accusations are coming and I'm not
saying I don't believe them I actually
am tempted to believe them I'm compelled
to believe them but this guy has no due
process this guy that we're talking
about accusations well passed the
statute of limitations does this mean
that whenever Democrats get upset in a
bad race they can find somebody and I'm
not saying that that is what's happening
in this case but if your principle holds
true then doesn't that mean they can
find somebody hurl some accusations and
we have to jump off the guy even if
there is no due process well there's a
big difference between accusations and
people coming forward with evidence
and with a repeated Pat surely your book
is pretty bad but also when it comes to
this guy's morality as a whole can we
just assume that he's going to all of a
sudden support all of his conservative
principles once he gets elected if we
can't trust him to be honest about his
history if we can't trust him to follow
the law and not be a scumbag in a way it
appears of course we really do public
life in public life his record has been
extremely conservative now are we saying
that it's someone who has ever broken
the law can't be a conservative well you
know there but for the grace of God go I
because all our sinners and fall short
of the glory of God right higher
standard than some random guy that's
creeping them all I think we totally I
totally buy that I mean this guy's
probably gonna lose anyway because that
was such a devastating press conference
yesterday I'm I'm just pointing out that
there are two different aspects here
we're talking about that this guy's
creepy personal life listen you've met a
lot of politicians I've met a lot of
politicians they're basically all
terrible people there are a few
exceptions that I could name but they're
all just desiccated awful people who
have no sense of integrity or soul or
really even wisdom they just have a
desire for power and so I don't know I'm
just not surprised by this I think it's
it's all if these accusations are true
it's really awful and the Luthor strange
campaign should have figured it out so
they could have knocked him out early
and we could have won this seat but
already had done some Oppo research but
that does raise a question why couldn't
strange figure this out why couldn't any
of his opponents in all of the years
he's been in public life figure it out
Josh last word I think the difference is
Roy Moore has premises entire campaign
on being holier-than-thou this is a
morally infused campaign he he said he's
going to legislate based on his moral
principles and if that's the case and
he's an amoral character then none of
his none of this follows then his
campaign doesn't make sense it's
inconsistent it's hypocritical and it's
I I don't think that he's going to win
and I don't think that what he
was should be viewed in any sort of
positive light regardless of the costs
and benefits of having it in the Senate
well that then that that's a fair point
to that in this case there is hypocrisy
there is whenever you're gonna stand for
a moral standard or a traditional
standard then you are gonna come under
the microscope for it and that's too bad
because the Democrats don't have any
standards they don't have any standards
at all which means they might be vicious
awful people but at least they aren't
hypocrites Rocha Foucault says that
hypocrisy is the tribute that vice pays
to virtue but in this case it's probably
enough to make this guy lose a Senate
race maybe he should lose the Senate
race but it's really it's really too bad
that his Republican opponent couldn't
have dug this up a while ago kicked him
out of the race and then we wouldn't be
having this conversation right now to
quote a great man sad maybe we should
have followed the candidate the
president Trump endorsed okay gentlemen
excellent thank you for being here Cabot
fellows from campus reform and Joshi
asthma I will talk to you both very soon
that's our show today it's a little
short today because we have to do the
conversation which is coming up at 5:00
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific log in it's
not too late subscribe now and well I
guess if you're watching it right now
you've already subscribed so thanks for
doing that send in some questions and I
will talk to you all in about an hour
I'm Michael knows as the Michael knows
show I will see you very shortly
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera and our associate producer
is Bailey Lynn the Michael Noel's show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017